[Музика]
добре, хлопці, тому я радий бачити вас знову,
і це останній урок на тему спорту
сьогодні, ми збираємося підсумувати
все, що ми говорили
під час наших уроків, тому сьогодні ми
збираємося переглянути
всі  словникова граматика, і у
вас буде завдання письма, тож давайте
почнемо
спочатку, я хочу познайомити вас зі своїм
найкращим інструментом, який я використовую для
лексико-запису, я не люблю паперові
словники,
я не люблю писати ручкою,
тому я використовую quizlet давайте візьмемо  подивіться,
що це таке, крім того, я
зробив для вас першу партію слів, якщо
ви перейдете за цим посиланням,
ви знайдете весь словниковий запас, який нам
потрібен для цього
підрозділу,
добре, хлопці, тому мені дуже
подобається цей веб-сайт, він дійсно допомагає мені вивчити
більше нового словникового запасу, і це  допомагає мені
впорядкувати
все, що мені потрібно знати, то що ми
маємо тут,
перша дуже корисна опція - це
картки,
тож подивіться, у
нас тут слово, і це
рефері,
і це ви можете прочитати переклад,
а потім диван  тренер
і я бачу переклад
am  anager і знову, якщо мені потрібен
переклад, я
перевіряю його, тоді капітан
добре наступний диктатор
гм суперник, якого
ви бачите, це дуже зручно, він говорить
вам вимову слова,
а наступний конкурент
сумісний марафон марафон добре,
я знаю переклад  фехтування
фехтування я не пам'ятаю, так
цей один боротьба боротьба
мм-хм важка атлетика
добре я пам'ятаю переклад Одрі
так, цей добре
добре їзда на велосипеді
добре баскетбол зрозуміло для мене
продовжувати гм фразові дієслова
добре так, цей з'їсти
я пам'ятаю це
приєднуйтесь до
[Музика]
Температурний
вірус добре, тому
ми переглянули слова для цього блоку, що
ще можна зробити на цьому веб-сайті,
подивіться тут, у вас є варіанти,
щоб ви могли вивчити слова,
давайте спробуємо, щоб
це було  і мені потрібно вибрати правильний
варіант
цей так, це правильний наступний,
гм, я б вибрав це
так, боротьба, якщо я не пам'ятаю
і зроблю неправильне припущення, наприклад,
я виконую цей поворот і кажу ні
система скаже мені вивчити це
ще раз,
і вона дасть мені правильний
переклад
, щоб продовжувати, добре,
і нехай це буде останній,
тому система знову скаже вам,
скільки слів ви знаєте
і скільки слів ви  оволодійте цим,
щоб мати цю статистику,
давайте повернемося назад і подивимося на інші варіанти,
тоді вам потрібно ввести текст,
і вам потрібно навчитися
писати ці слова, тому супернічний означає, що
конкурент
конкурент відповідає неправильно,
чому це був суперник,
це нормально зробити  помилки, коли ми робимо
помилки
ми навчимося давайте спробуємо ще раз на каштанах
позаду
о, це
конкурент конкурент відповідь так, цей
правильний,
давайте переглянемо інші варіанти
добре, тепер ви можете перевірити своє правопис,
і ви можете пройти тест
тож ви бачите, що це статистика,
наприклад, три відсотки
закінчено, крім того, ви можете використовувати
цю панель, і ви можете додати
її або відредагувати, ви можете додати її до свого власного
словника і ви можете надіслати його своєму
фрі  nds,
і ви можете роздрукувати його,
щоб мати друковану версію, якщо вам потрібно,
а якщо вона вам не потрібна
, ви можете видалити її, щоб у
вас було посилання у презентації та
посилання під відео на YouTube.
не соромтеся отримати цю партію слів
і переглянути її, крім того, ви можете безкоштовно завантажити
цю програму
на свій смартфон і використовувати її в
будь-який час, коли вам потрібно
переглянути або вивчити новий словниковий запас,
тому ми переглянули словниковий запас, і
ви готові виконувати ще кілька вправ,
тому  перше, про який вид спорту, на вашу
думку
, говорить кожен глядач, давайте
прочитаємо речення
і вгадаємо вид спорту,
тому першим, який точно був падінням,
суддя має бути сліпим,
що це за вид спорту, що це, хлопці,
добре, тому правильна відповідь
- футбол футбол  регбі
хокей і баскетбол
добре давайте подивимося на другу
ще одну блискучу подачу я думаю, що
вона виграє матч
блискуча подача де ми подаємо
добре так що це теніс
настільний теніс і сквош
добре подивіться на  наступний
я думаю, що він буде нокаутований
у наступному раунді,
нокаутований, і
це бокс і бойові
мистецтва наступний він побив світовий
рекорд тричі цього року я впевнений, що
він виграє цю гонку,
що  тричі став чемпіоном світу,
і ключове слово тут - гонка,
так що це правильно,
це автогонки або
формула-1, добре, і останній
на даний момент - нічия, нам потрібно ще
один гол, щоб виграти матч,
це нічия, це означає, що
це  однаково, як один один
два два, це нічия, а комусь
потрібен ще один гол, тож цей вид спорту
знову футбол,
чи футбол чи хокей,
тому всі види спорту ви можете
побачити червоним,
і я впевнений, що ви знаєте їх,
давайте підемо далі  добре,
тепер наступне, що ми переглянули під час
цього блоку,
були часи,
і перші часи, які ми переглянули, були
в теперішньому простому і теперішньому
тривалому,
обидва наявні означають, що відбуваються
зараз або приблизно в
момент розмови або щодня,
давайте пригадаємо, тому перший присутній
sim
це звичайна дія
, яку ви робите щодня,
наприклад, я ходжу на роботу
щодня, або
я граю в теніс щосуботи чи
неділі,
або я граю в теніс щосуботи чи
або я ходжу на альпінізм
кожного літа, так що
це рутина  дія це відбувається
щодня, навпаки
теперішнє безперервне це те, що
відбувається зараз що
я роблю я стою
що ти робиш
можливо ти щось їси чи, можливо,
ти щось п'єш,
але я впевнений, що ти слухаєш і
дивитися цей урок
добре, тому це дія, яка відбувається
в момент розмови, і
лайфхаки,
які допомагають нам визначити, які десятки
нам потрібно використовувати, тому для теперішнього простого
це щодня
зазвичай часто іноді
рідко рідко наба,
тому слова  які показують нам рутину
і на даний момент безперервний, який ми маємо
на даний момент, дивіться,
слухайте добре, тому давайте
ще трохи потренуємося перше
речення
подивіться Полін квіти
і ми маємо  дієслово поливати,
тож подивіться тут у нас є підказка,
і це допоможе нам визначити
час,
тож час присутній безперервно,
а речення має бути дивитися
полін поливає квіти
це відбувається це відбувається зараз
подивіться  добре, другий
послухай, дівчата, а дієслово
знову співають, ми знову маємо це,
ми маємо тут, слухаємо,
і він показує нам, що дія
відбувається зараз і знову, тому ми маємо тут
тепер безперервний
ще раз, тому  дівчата
співають пісню добре номер три,
вона зазвичай додому автобусом,
тож і у нас є водій, вона зазвичай
їздить додому автобусом, у нас
зазвичай, і це слово показує
нам теперішній простий час
добре, давайте їдемо далі, так Джек
Джек до своєї бабусі щодня
кожен день, це рутинна дія,
і вона присутня безперервно,
ви повинні пам'ятати, що Джек - це він, і
вам потрібно використовувати
кінцівку, щоб Джек ходив
до своєї бабусі щодня
знову, наступний - дивіться
Саллі та Джоуї  ну теніс
так  що вони роблять, вони
грають в теніс
відразу наступного Неллі чашка чаю
щоранку щоранку знову
це рутина, це відбувається щодня,
тож Неллі пам'ятай, будь ласка, кінець
Неллі п'є чашку кави
щоранку добре, наступний
ми можемо  не грай у теніс
зараз, і у нас дощ, якщо
зараз, то він присутній безперервно,
тому зараз йде дощ
, це правильно.
безперервно,
тому Білл робить
домашнє завдання зараз добре номер дев'ять
Джейн завжди її домашнє завдання в своїй кімнаті
завжди дія відбувається, можливо,
щодня або принаймні у
вихідні
або принаймні, коли вона виконує домашнє завдання,
що було натяком, тому Джейн завжди
її виконує  домашнє завдання в її
кімнаті останнє для цих двох
часів хлопчики іноді в парку
іноді знову цього не відбувається
зараз це буває іноді час від часу
і знову ми говоримо про
рутину,
тому  хлопчики іноді бігають
по парку, так що це все з
Present Simple і Present
Continue
ми можемо піти далі, так що наступну
пару часів ви запам'ятаєте Present
Perfect
і Past Simple давайте почнемо
згадувати Present Perfect
Добре, Ви пам'ятаєте лайфхак, який
я показав  ви під час останнього уроку,
тож якщо у вас є слова eva
ніколи ще з тих пір
і вже вам потрібно використати Present
Perfect,
це дія в минулому, але
воно має відношення до теперішнього,
воно має результат у теперішньому,
наприклад, я  щойно
снідав я ситий я не хочу
їсти
або я вже пішов на пробіжку
сьогодні вранці, і я закінчив зі
своїми сьогоднішніми вправами, тому
ще раз швидкі дії, але з
результатом
у теперішньому, а не в
минулому просто  це минула дія,
яка залишається в минулому, і
вам потрібен его вчора, останній
або точна дата в минулому,
навіть якщо я скажу, що
снідав п’ять хвилин тому,
мені потрібно використовувати минулий час
минулий простий час,
але якщо я скажу  Я щойно
поснідав, я буду використовувати Present
Perfect
Okay, тож давайте
спробуємо виконати ці вправи, тому перший
сам новий мобільний телефон кілька місяців
тому, ми маємо
тут дуже сильний натяк на
те, що мета, яка точно минула
простий, так що
сам минулий простий
придбав новий мобільний телефон кілька місяців тому
добре, тепер подивіться на друге
речення,
ось ситуація, і все починається
знову
з мобільного телефону я не знав, що він
купив новий мобільний  телефон
так, він їсть вже кілька місяців,
тому він купив його кілька місяців тому,
і він все ще має його, ця
дія пов’язана з теперішнім, тому
вам потрібно поставити це в
ідеальний теперішній час
так, він має
це вже кілька місяців,
добре  наступний
минулого року ми в Шотландію на наші
канікули
минулого року точно
не думаємо багато, що минуло просто,
тому минулого року ми поїхали
в Шотландію на наші канікули,
добре, наступний ти виглядаєш розслаблено
я розмовляю з тобою зараз, ти виглядаєш
розслаблений,
і людина відповідає так,
я маю vacatio  n
Отже, ми бачимо результат, людина
розслаблена
, і він не втомився,
тому він каже, що
він щойно був
у відпустці так, я
тільки що був у відпустці
добре номер п'ять, я не можу
приєднатися до вас зараз, тому що
я ще маю домашнє завдання
Ви пам'ятаєте це правило ніколи,
просто
ще добре, так
і, безумовно, це має бути
ідеальним,
і, звичайно, є результат, коли
людина
не може приєднатися до гри, тому що
він не виконав домашнє завдання,
тому правильною відповіддю тут буде я
ще не зробив своє домашнє завдання
добре номер шість я
все моє домашнє завдання вчора вдень,
так що вчора знову
так що ми маємо тут, якщо вчора це
я зробив усе своє домашнє завдання вчора
вдень у
нас є точна дата в минулому,
тепер номер сім
востаннє ти втомився
ми запитуємо, що відбувається з людиною
зараз, що є результатом її чи її
дій,
і людина каже так,
важкий день день не закінчився
день не
закінчився, тому у мене
був важкий день і  результатом цієї
дії є thi
s людина втомилася
добре, я сподіваюся, що ви добре
переглянули часи,
і що у вас ніколи не буде
питань щодо
цих чотирьох часів.
розвиваючи нашу розмову,
готуючи діалоги, ми розвивали
наш словниковий запас
та навички письма, виконуючи деякі словникові
вправи та виконуючи деякі граматичні
вправи,
тепер ви можете використати всі свої знання
в письмовому завдання, тож давайте прочитаємо
оголошення
та відповімо на запитання, чи б ви хотіли
приєднатися до клубу
чому чи чому ні так, шкільний клуб тай-чи,
ну, ти хочеш спробувати щось нове
чи хочеш навчитися розслаблятися та
контролювати своє тіло
та розум, якщо ти прийдеш і приєднаєшся до цього
класного клубу тай-чи, тепер
тобі не потрібно  маєте будь-який досвід у
тай-чи,
просто будьте відкриті, ми навчимо вас
всьому, що вам потрібно знати про це
стародавнє бойове мистецтво,
цей класний клуб тай-чи збирається в
шкільному спортзалі на w  середа
о 17:00, де зручний одяг,
щоб отримати додаткову інформацію, зателефонуйте Шарлотті на
нуль сім шість один три два сім
чотири двічі дев'ять сім або відвідайте
наш новий веб-сайт,
тому дуже приємне оголошення, і
ви хотіли б приєднатися до цього клубу, якщо
вас цікавить бойовий спорт  мистецтва,
можливо, а якщо ви ні,
можливо, ви хотіли б зробити
оголошення для свого
власного спортивного клубу, тож
давайте ще раз прочитаємо це оголошення
та приділимо трохи часу, щоб відповісти на
запитання
добре, приділіть хвилинку та прочитайте його
ще раз
, зробіть
[Музика]
[  Музика]
добре, давайте відповімо на запитання, тож
перше,
де збирається клуб,
добре, щоб клуб збирався
в шкільному спортзалі, добре,
друге запитання, коли збирався клуб,
добре, вони
збиралися в середу о 17:00,
що вони роблять у клубі
що вони роблять у клубі,
вони вчаться розслаблятися
та контролювати своє тіло та розум,
добре, як отримати більше інформації
про клуб,
щоб отримати додаткову інформацію, зателефонуйте до
Шарлотти
або відвідайте наш новий веб-сайт
oka  y тому давайте розглянемо ближче,
вам знадобиться порада, як написати
таку рекламу, тому вам потрібна корисна
мова в оголошеннях,
подивіться перша підказка: ви
повинні використовувати
короткі запитання, щоб зацікавити людей,
як це було в  текст Чи хочете ви спробувати
щось нове
чи вас цікавлять бойові мистецтва, чи
хотіли б ви спробувати йогу, третє
запитання, щоб
привернути увагу, тоді
ви даєте важливу інформацію в
чітких
реченнях, не робіть речення
довгими, робіть їх короткими та зрозумілими,
ми зазвичай  зустрінемося в п'ятницю о 18:00
у спортивному залі інформація
коротка,
але справді зрозуміла, потім
використовуйте імперативи, вони кажуть людям, що
робити,
принесіть відкритий розум, зателефонуйте йому,
сядьте, розслабтеся, це приклади
імперативів
і останній або вони кажуть  люди,
чого
не слід робити, не сидіть
, не приносьте взуття, не чекайте,
тому використовуйте короткі запитання, потім дайте
важливу інформацію
в дуже чіткій формі, а потім
використовуйте імперативи, щоб сказати, що робити, а
що ні  зробити, і ваше
домашнє завдання полягатиме в тому, щоб написати таке
оголошення,
тому практика стане ідеальною, якщо ви
тренуєтеся,
тоді ви станете ідеальними напишіть
оголошення для нового
клубу у вашій школі займайтеся будь-яким видом спорту
займайтеся будь-яким видом діяльності, який вам подобається, клуб може
бути у
будь-який вільний час  активність у своєму
оголошенні
включайте цю інформацію, де ви зустрічаєтеся,
коли зустрічаєтеся з тим, що ви робите, і як
ви можете отримати більше інформації, ці
чотири пункти є обов’язковими для
того, щоб написати про це, ви не можете
виконати жодного з цих пунктів, які ви бачите
добре, тому не соромтеся  щоб надсилати свої
оголошення на мою електронну пошту, ви можете побачити це
нижче
olga chistikova ad gmail.com
я постараюся прочитати якомога більше і
дати вам відгук,
тому хлопці, це кінець нашого підрозділу спорту,
наступна тема буде ще більше
цікаво
слідкуйте за нашими уроками та слідкуйте за оновленнями до зустрічі
[Музика].